and joining us now secretary of health
and human services alex azar
mr secretary as we said an fda
advisory panel is going to be
considering
emergency authorization for the pfizer
vaccine on thursday two questions
first of all is there anything in the
technical information
that pfizer has presented that raises
any red flags and second
assuming that the panel approves how
long will it take
the fda to give the green light and for
the vaccine to be distributed
so chris i've not heard of any red flags
but uh i
i'll have to leave that to the career
scientists at fda who are digging
through
all of the data in terms of timing
assuming everything is on track and the
advisory committee goes well we
could see authorization of the pfizer
vaccine within days after the advisory
committee and then moderna one week
later
is their advisory committee and
similarly days after that but
i'm going to leave that to the fda
career scientist to determine if
everything's on track
but if the panel approves on december
10th
how soon might the vaccine the pfizer
vaccine be out for people
really within days chris what we've said
is within 24 hours of fda
green lighting with authorization we'll
ship to all of the states and
territories that
that we work with and within hours they
can be vaccinating
president-elect biden says that his
transition team has looked
at the administration's distribution
plan
and that they have found some problems
take a look
there is no detailed plan that we've
seen anyway
as to how you get the vaccine out of a
container
into an injection syringe into
somebody's arm
is the president elect wrong
with all respect that's just nonsense we
have
comprehensive plans from the cdc working
with 64 public health jurisdictions
across the country as our governors have
laid out very detailed plans that we've
worked with them on
we're leveraging our retail pharmacies
our hospitals our public health
departments
our community health centers we have the
mckesson-built
kits that have the syringes the diluent
the needles the ppe to administer
this is being micromanaged and
controlled by the united states military
as well as our incredible private sector
we do hundreds of millions of
vaccinations a year we're leveraging the
systems
that are known and that work here in the
united states
not that this is the administration's
problem but you originally promised that
there would be 300 million
doses of the vaccine by the end of the
year it now looks like it's going to be
roughly about 10 of that 35 to 40
million
doses because of various supply problems
on the part of the vaccine maker so this
isn't going to go
just according to the book there are
going to be some obstacles
well chris uh we're looking at really
historic accomplishment you know
six months from when that the
president's direction i created
operation warp speed
you know we're looking at having
multiple vaccines fda approved and
close to 40 million doses of fda
approved vaccine releasable by the end
of this year what i've always said is
high tens of millions of doses of fda
gold standard vaccine by the end of the
year
we'll have that we'll have 40 million
releasable as well as a
comparable amount that will be going
through final quality control for
release in january
and then hundreds of millions of doses
from multiple manufacturers as we go
into next year really a historic
achievement and
it is the light at the end of the tunnel
it's what we need people to hang in
there
with washing their hands watching their
distance wearing their face coverings
when they can't watch their distance
because
those bright days are ahead and we want
everyone to be there to get their
vaccination
but there is a hitch in this and that is
as many as 40 percent of americans
according to polls
say they may not get the vaccine and one
of the reasons is because
concern about politics i want to put up
a tweet
on november 9th the president tweeted
the us fda
and the democrats didn't want to have me
get a vaccine win
prior to the election so instead it came
out five days later
and when the white house chief of staff
called in the fda commissioner twice
this week
to ask why it's taking the agency so
long
to approve the vaccine the fda
commissioner stephen hahn felt the need
to write this we will make sure that our
scientists take the time they need
to make an appropriate decision mr
secretary why not stop
the politics and let the scientists do
their job
chris that's exactly what i've done and
i've reassured you and others throughout
this process and that's what's happened
five independent checks independent data
safety monitoring board independent drug
company reviewing the data to make sure
it
meets their ethical standards i
understand i understand that
you've got the president tweeting that
somehow the decision on when to release
the vaccine
was an effort to defeat him in the
election you've got the white house
chief of
staff calling in the fda commissioner
and saying let's get going faster
you may be letting the scientists do
their job but people in the white house
don't appear to be
well chris the facts just show that the
five individ independent checks we put
in the system are what are driving this
train here and we're also going to work
to help improve vaccine confidence
working especially with trusted voices
and underserved communities
but the most important thing is going to
be as we progressively roll out vaccine
to people
the positive experiences that they have
by word of mouth and reference are going
to be what really drive i think
increasing vaccine confidence as we see
the end of the end of the day of this
pandemic eventually
all right let's turn from the vaccine to
the terrible situation
that we find ourselves in right now as i
said that we are seeing a record number
of covid cases hospitalizations and
deaths
and here's what we heard this week from
the head of the cdc dr robert redfield
take a look
the reality is december and january and
february
are going to be rough times i actually
believe they're going to be the most
difficult
time in the public health history of
this nation
secretary azar isn't this the result of
a
massive failure by president trump and
his administration
chris we're seeing these surge in cases
in the united states but also in germany
france uk
spain it's about behavior and cold
weather people are going indoors they're
not mining the 3ws
they're not wearing their face coverings
we're engaged in indoor behaviors where
we let our guard down
we need people to renew their commitment
but we're also not without tools
we have complete visibility thanks to
tools that i built here earlier this
year
so that we know what's going on in the
nation's hospitals we're being proactive
and reaching out to them we're getting
them supply
chris it's really important that people
know that we're working to protect them
they're getting supplies
secretary azar let me ask you about some
of those tools let's just take
the issue of masks here's what
president-elect biden said this week
i'm going to ask the public for 100 days
to mask just 100 days to mask not
forever 100 days
but back on april 3rd when the cdc
director dr
robert redfield first recommended that
all americans wear masks
here's what happens sir we know that a
face barrier can actually interrupt the
number of virus particles
that can go from one person to the other
so it's voluntary you don't have to do
it
they suggest it for a period of time
but this is voluntary
i don't think i'm going to be doing it
if president trump had worn a mask then
and urged everyone to wear a mask then
back in april
the way joe biden is right now wouldn't
we be in much better shape
well chris i i welcome vice president
biden to the club since the middle of
april the president's guidelines for
reopening you have called
an alexa the president has called the
president
the president has called mass patriotic
acts
every one of his top advisers we are out
there saying wear your mass
we talk about the data you know chris at
one meter if two people wear the mass it
can reduce viral transmission by
72 percent protecting both the source
and the recipient we've got the data
mass work we encourage people please
wear a mask
when you can't engage in social
distancing
but but first of all it's it's the
president-elect joe biden secretary azar
and secondly
the fact is the president said on the
first day april 3rd he wasn't
going to wear a mask he didn't wear a
mask in public
for three months until july and just
last night at that rally
in georgia not only didn't he wear a
mask but i was watching the rally
thousands of people packed together
none i could see wearing a mask that is
a direct violation
of what the cdc and you are recommending
chris our advice is always the same wash
your hands watch your distance wear face
carvings when you can't watch your
distance and be especially careful of
those settings like
overcrowded indoor bars and restaurants
or multi-family household gatherings
we're going to let your guard down and
take that face covering off so chris our
advice is the same regardless of the
setting
and regardless of whether the president
ignores it or not regardless of the
setting
our advice remains the same and the
president is called mask wearing
patriotic
we encourage people to wear face
coverings when they can't maintain their
social distance
finally you said this recently about
lockdowns
you don't need lockdowns the data
clearly demonstrate the interventions we
need are simple
they're demonstrated they're proven but
they're not forcing
they're not forcing people to stay in
their home shutting down our businesses
shutting our schools
is california governor newsome wrong to
say
with in in the state of california
literally
in many places running out of icu beds
because of such a surge of
hospitalization
is he wrong to say that he's going to
impose some stay-at-home orders
chris our community mitigation efforts
have to be based in science and evidence
where we lose
public support and compliance for them
we know
that our workplaces our universities our
k-12 schools flying on airplanes
are not major vectors of disease
transmission it's overcrowded indoor
restaurants and bars
it is multi-household indoor gatherings
where we let our guard
down these are the things we need to
protect against if we
go too far and we defer to governors on
the steps they need to take
it's their call but we if we go beyond
science and evidence we will undermine
public support you know as dr fauci said
it the most important thing is to
convince people why
they should wear face coverings more
than mandating it's get people to
understand why it matters to protect
them and their loved ones
to wear face coverings and that's our
job convincing people of science and
evidence-based
interventions well i agree with you as
you say right there
wear a mask i wish everyone did
secretary azar thank you
thanks for your time this weekend we'll
be tracking what the fda panel does on
thursday sir